t
annoncé son départ il y a plus
de 10 ans. Élyse Allard.
♪ Vous travaillez fort
pour votre argent ♪
♪ Alors on va
vous en donner plus ♪hahahahahae
surface, Zellers, connaît
alors son apogée au Canada,
60 ans après sa fondation
par l'Ontarien Walter èèèèèèèèè,
ZeZellers mise sur la marchandie
à bas prix.
25 ans après son ouverture,mams
et emploie 3000 personnes.
Puis, en 1981, la Compagnie
de la Baie d'Hudson acquiert
la marque. La concurrence fée et
de la fin de Zellers.nenenenenet
acquiert la vamamamajorité
des locaux de la compagnie.rsrss
ferment en0.0.0.
BENOIT DUGUAY,n n n n n n n n nM
- Àpopopoque, ça marchait déjà
moins. C'est pas pour rien
Quand quelque chose va très
bien, tu le vends pas!
- HBC, toujours propriétaire
des Canadiens par surprise
en annonçant l'ouverture
de 25 magasins Zellersuxuxuxuxux
de la Baie d'Hudson.
Ils prendront la forme
de départements de prèss.s.s.s..
Au Québec, Anjou, Rosemère,
Québec, Sherbrooke et Gatineau
accueilleront le concept.
- Mo
J'aimais ça, Zellers, oui.
Tuaiaiaiais là, tu trouvais
de tout.
Bien, je suis contentee e e e ç.
- Moi, ça me semble être
un geste un peu désespéré,élélé:
de l'ultra-chic avec du plus bas
de gamme...
- J'ai l'impression qu'on est
un petit peu à la re d d d d d .
Je sais pas, mais moi, je suis
un petit peu passée à d'autres
choses, je pense.
HBC lance la boutique en
Zellers.ca.
- Quand tu penses achatueueueues
à La Baie? Non, hein? Bien,
pourquoi tu penserais à Zellers?
- HBC pourrait étendre
le concept à d'autres magasins,
siadadadadadiens réadoptent
la marque.
Ici Élyse Allara,a,a,a,a,a,a,aa